hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
um it looks like this is called beta
male
wrecked her home before i start the
video do not forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe as you guys know
the more followers or subscribers that i
have
the more motivated i am to make content
so if you really like my content you
want me to make more do not forget to
subscribe
that supports me and supports my
business oh and don't forget to comment
i have a feeling i'm gonna have a very
different interpretation of this
just based on what i've heard about this
guy so just comment if you guys think
i'm right or i'm wrong
[Music]
okay so well you said i looked young
i'm 29 so i am that's correct me
that's nice so i'm single no kids
okay so and your expertise
um how
sorry i'm super nervous that's okay
so what is your advice of attracting
someone who's not a beta male
a beta male
quick question like what would you guys
define a beta male ass when i think of a
beta male
i think of a guy who just like doesn't
have a spine
but that doesn't necessarily mean i'm
right but that's like what i think of
watching your videos for the past week
everyone kept on sharing like your viral
videos
and i actually like went on your youtube
video and started watching like a lot of
your older stuff
and realized that you did have like a
lot of good advice
and that you're only trying to help so i
watched a video
last night that you said the reason why
there's so many alpha females
is because of beta males so basically
just like a sieve
yeah beta males
in the dating sense are men
who don't step into what i call
confident intelligent and assertive okay
there's not one reason
for everything so he's saying that
there's a lot of alpha females
because there's a lot of beta males and
i'm sure that's true on some
level but like you also have to take
into account other factors like
you know the development of birth
control that gave women way more
options to like have kids later and
develop more of a career than they
did before yeah it's
i don't think it's that important i'm
gonna keep going men who don't lead
alpha males are men
who step into their masculinity they're
confident
intelligent and assertive
now this now that is different than many
people the word alpha
and beta gets so deluded but really what
it's coming down to is a man who's a
masculine frame
and is willing to step forth and leave
you know and that enables a woman to be
what i call feminine beautiful and
inspirational stay in her ultimate
feminine
which is honestly the best place for
both of the genders
um i say that pressure is made for
shoulders not for hips
so when you say a beta
are you talking about a man who can lead
you
or you talk about just a an effeminate
weak
submissive man um i don't like using
generalities
because it really just depends on the
couple
like some people are more comfortable
with one thing some people are more
comfortable with another like
but i i don't think that's the point of
this video based on the comments so i'm
going to just keep going
submissive weak super feminine
when's the last time you were in a
relationship
my last relationship was one and a half
years ago
i wanted to dance so i was with him
for four years so we
were married okay so we were dating for
six months and then he proposed to me
so our engagement lasted a year and a
half
and then a year and a half later i found
out he was cheating on me
with his manager and then we got
divorced
so
this manager i'm assuming there's a
woman
i'm sorry assuming his manager was a
woman female
yes
yes sis you gotta leave like
it's not even about like like how would
you be able to trust someone again
if they cheat on you you would never
know if they're telling the truth about
anything
all right um how did you find out
i found out from one of his
ex-co-workers actually
so there was a lot of like signs
and i called about when you were working
did you have to work yes i was working
full time
was what were you guys splitting the
bills 50 50
yes um
and how old was he were you guys the
same age
he's a was a little bit older than me
all right so
after you found out about the affair
what did he say
well when i first called him out on it
he still tried to deny it
and then i found like some pictures on
his email
okay so then i sent those to him and
then he couldn't deny it
after that and that that was the
and that was the dissolution of the
match
yes so i did not want to be with him
after that i found out that he was
basically
cheating on me with her um while we were
engaged
so the entire time yeah yeah take the
trash out
uh are you you are sitting down
am i sitting no you're sitting down you
might want to you might want to lean
back
because i don't know what you ladies
expect for me the kind of man that you
want to marry is attractive to other
women but you sound like your husband
went through his best to keep it from
you he did not put it in your face
oh i'm sorry i couldn't quite hear you
yeah wait
do people actually think like this
oh my gosh i really hope
people don't actually listen to he's
telling this girl
to go back that she should expect her
husband to cheat
sounds like he did his best to hide it
from you
you did not put it in your face
i did a video on monday talking about
high value men cheat
ladies i don't know if you what meant if
your husband was
attractive to you he's attracted to a
dirty woman
but he was trying to keep it behind your
back cheating with the married woman
what do you think you're going to find
out here now you think you're thinking
the next man you find is going to just
be loyal to you
yeah well i definitely have a lot of
trust issues my goodness this is just
crazy to me get
ladies do not do not listen
kevin samuels is clearly a douchebag
anyone okay you go on my youtube channel
right
go to my earlier videos you're gonna
find a video
that's of a house tour that's my parents
house
right huge mansion i'm not saying this
to brag
the reason i'm saying this is because i
know rich people and half the time
the people that look like kevin samuels
and talk like kevin samuels
and talk a big game about getting women
and have all these fancy things
i don't i don't know him personally so
i'm not gonna pretend like
i know everything it's just my vibe half
the people like that one don't even have
as much money as they say
and two don't they don't know what
they're talking about
i'm telling you guys i know rich people
i know a lot of very wealthy people
and they're not cheating on their wives
half of the people that are actually
passionate about what they're doing like
they don't have time they don't have
time to do that so don't
don't let guys like this scare you
and half the time like the guys that act
like they're rich
like they might make a lot of money but
half of them spend
so much money i'm gonna keep going i'm
gonna keep going i just
this is just crazy to me because now
well
is it trust see this is what i don't
understand
let's take it away from you because it's
too cursed
in the animal kingdom namely the species
of
our mammal the of the male of the
species and mammals
normally monogamous
not men me no
so you gave up your husband who proposed
you in six months to marry you
and you were building a life with her
but he was cheating with a married woman
so she was talented so she had a husband
too
they were seeing one another the only
way he found out about
is from a dirty mac and or somebody in a
co-work
who was probably just hating on it was
it a man who told you
yes of course because he wanted to get
in your ass
so you look this is what i've noticed in
life i don't even really want to finish
this
people give the advice that they wish
they had themselves
so if a girl is telling girls
to go be like sleep with whoever you
want that's going to make you happy like
you're an empowered woman
half the time it's because that's what
she did and she wants to feel
okay with what she did
and i i guarantee i guarantee just from
watching this video that's what kevin
samuels said
he probably was married before i
guarantee he was married before i
guarantee he ended up divorced
and i guarantee that he cheated
like and so he couldn't stay faithful so
he's trying to tell
other people that this is just what high
value men do
and it's just not true
the internet's crazy people will say
stuff that's like crazy on the internet
to get views
i think that people cheat right in
general like
okay so 25 of marriages see at least one
incident of infidelity
so if you take that as a 25 percent of
merit so one in four
right obviously like the guys with more
money
have more options and obviously like
more of them are going to cheat because
more of them have the opportunity to
but acting like every guy that makes a
lot of money and is considered like high
value is just going to cheat on their
wife or whatever like it's just kind of
a sad way to look at the world and i
swear
i know so many rich guys that are so
just preoccupied with what they're doing
like like i have brothers that are on
track to be millionaires by the time
they're like 30
40 years old and like
i know them they would never like never
in a million years
cheat like on his girlfriend because
half the time he's just playing video
games
he's just chilling like i swear
like this guy i guarantee he's just
saying it because that
i guarantee he's just saying this
because he couldn't stay faithful so
he's trying to like justify what he did
by telling other people like this is
just how it is but it's not
like wrecked your own home you
wrecked your own home
so you think i should have stayed with
him when he was cheating the entire time
you ain't gonna like my show no yeah
cause now what you got
well hopefully to find someone who's
loyal
nope
we are men don't cheat we exercise
options
because it was your husband an
attractive man yes
is he successful yeah i'd say so
and you think you're the only vagina
that wanted this penis
where do you where do you ladies get
this [ __ ] from
it's not like you got a guy who's on
fries at mcdonald's he wiped you
and he tried to keep it from
if you went but you let some
and he tried to keep it from you like if
he
it's one thing if you have an
understanding like some couples go into
things and they have an understanding
like
that the guy is gonna do that and the
girl knows going in
but if the guy is gonna lie to you about
that and not let you know up front
how can you trust him with anything
with anything how do you know he's
telling the truth about anything like
oh my goodness this is just crazy to me
somebody else come to you and say hey
guess where
oh my god because this guy the guy who
told you he wasn't a cousin or brother
right
no no how did you know um
i used to work with him right did he
ever ask you out
no right did he ever show any interest
in you when you used to work with him
no he was married is he hetero is he
homosexual
no so a guy that you used to work with
who can look in the mirror and see and
attract a woman he never asks you out
but then all of a sudden
he comes playing on the white horse
i guarantee i i don't know who kevin
samuels is
i've never really looked into his past
but i guarantee this man is divorced
i guarantee he cheated and i bet you i
bet you
a beta male wrecked his marriage i
guarantee i guarantee
white hat telling you hey by the way
your husband's cheating on you
did you ask him um
i didn't ask him
if that's your actual friend like i get
like not wanting
to be in other people's business but if
that's your actual friend
because it was the right thing to do you
have your goddamn mind it's not the
right thing to do
you wrecked your home based upon a punk
ass beta man
you came in asking about beta male right
and what happened to you you allowed a
beta to run you away from your alpha
yeah you were a wife he was cheating
with another married woman but it ain't
like he was being sloppy with it
and you allowed a beta male come in hey
by the way
oh man what do you have to show for uh
well i feel like he kind of was being
sloppy because i called him out multiple
times but he didn't know he wasn't being
sloppy
was he being sloppy this is terrible you
didn't find out about it you didn't find
stuff you had to be told
so ladies understand something the men
who come to you
who are telling you this [ __ ] normally
if this is a state of nature
we would get rid of being like that
they're only allowed to live because
i'm done with this video but
i really hope people don't listen to
this this is terrible
like i know so many millionaires that
are absolutely
obsessed with their wives i know so many
like i have so many relatives that would
literally never do
anything like that and i swear i'm not
saying this to brag i'm not saying this
to like
throw it in your face i just don't want
people to think
that because this guy this guy
thinks that this is how the world works
because i bet you this is how
his world works i guarantee that's how
his world worked so that's why he's
telling all these women
this terrible advice some of the stuff
he said is true about beta
alpha males like sure
obviously if a guy has more options he's
more likely to cheat
people cheat no matter where they are in
this like
hierarchy yeah this he's out of his
goddamn mind
if you guys like this type of reaction
if you want to see more
please let me know in the comments do
not forget to subscribe
as you guys know i'm really trying to
build a brand out here
i really want to create more content for
you guys in order to do that
i need subscribers i mean every
subscriber
helps so do not forget do not forget i
will talk to you guys next time bye